Benim sçik 9.0 cofa YouTube'un en büyük
cof kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz. Evet,
Zedova öğretmenleri ile beraber
yaptığımız okula destek kampımızın bugün
geldik artık son videosuna. Bugün
bölgeleri ve bölge sınırlarını
öğreneceğiz. Ama bakın bu konu çok
önemli bir konudur. Çünkü üniversite
sınavına gittiğinizde her sene bir soru
karşınıza çıkar bundan. Tabii ki siz
üniversite sınavına giderken sizin
sınavınız biraz daha farklı olacak ama
sonuçta bu konu önemli bir konu ve
buradan soru gelecek sana. O gün soru
geldiğinde benim şu suoganımı
hatırlayacaksın. Yunus hocayla bir defa
öğren. Bir daha asla unutma. Çünkü biz
bu 9. sınıf boyunca aslında seni
üniversite sınavına hazırladık. Sen de
öyle hazırlandın aslında farkında
değilsin. Bunu 34 yıl sonra tekrar
üniversite sınavına hazırlanmaya
başladığında anlayacaksın. Evet. Ben
bunu biliyordum diyeceksin. Ben şunu
biliyordum diyeceksin. Senin için
üniversite sınavına hazırlanmak coğrafya
dersi için sadece bir genel tekrardan
ibaret olacak. O yüzden şimdi dersi
dinlerken dikkatli dinle ki 3 yıl sonra
rahat et. Sınavda da bu yazılı sınavında
da bundan soru çıkacaktır. Merak etme
diyoruz. Ve o zaman ne diyoruz? Yunus
hocayla. Bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Zeduava ile eğitim her
[Müzik]
yerde. Evet geldik bölge ve bölge
sınırlarını öğreneceğiz. Bunun PDF'ini
böyle zedua.com sitesine yükledik
gençler. Oradan indirip
kullanabilirsiniz. Şimdi bakın, biz bazı
sınırlandırmaları yapmamız lazım ki
tanımlamalar yapabilelim. Yani biz
bölgeleri ayırmazsak nasıl insanlara
tarif edebiliriz ya da kendimiz bunları
nasıl tam olarak öğrenebiliriz? Çeşitli
kriterlere göre bölgeleri ayırmak
zorundayız. Çünkü bunlar üzerinden
yatırımlardan tutun da tanımlamalara
kadar birçok işimizi bu bölge
sınırlarının tanımlanması ve
belirlenmesi üzerinden yapıyoruz.
Gençler geçmişte bölgeleri farklı
ayırıyorduk. Artık farklı ayırıyoruz.
Geçmişte nasıydı biliyor musunuz?
Aslında biliyorsunuz Karadeniz bölgesi,
Güneydoğu Anadolu bölgesi, Doğu Anadolu
bölgesi gibi bölge sınırları ayrımız
vardı. Sonra o kaldırıldı. Sonra ne oldu
biliyor musunuz? Aslında mantıklı olan
da bu. Mesela bitki örtüsüne göre
Türkiye'yi bölgelere ayırıyoruz.
Toprağına göre bölgelere ayırıyoruz.
Nüfus yoğunluğuna göre, yerleşimlere
göre, petrol üretim alanlarına göre,
doğalgaz üretim alanlarına göre
bölgeleri ayırıyoruz. Bu bölge ayrımı
çok daha kullanışlı, çok daha işimize
yarayacak türden. O yüzden bölgeleri
gençler biz artık yeni kriterlere göre
ayırıyoruz ve karşımıza yeni bölge
türleri çıkıyor. Aslında o geçmişteki
Karadeniz bölgesi, Marmara bölgesi gibi
ayrımları kullanmıyoruz. Bölge dediğimiz
şeyin tanımını öğrenmen gerekiyor. Çünkü
bu sana yazılıda böyle tanım olarak
sorar öğretmenin. Bak kendi içinde
çeşitli benzerlikler gösteren çiziyorum
aynı zamanda ben sana bunu. Şimdi bak
şöyle bir kare çizeyim. Bu kare
üzerinden anlatayım sana. Bunun şu içini
maviye kareli yapalım. Şöyle bak. Kendi
içinde çeşitli benzerlikler gösteren.
Görüyor musunuz şu maviyi? Bak bu kendi
içinde çeşitli benzerlikler gösteriyor.
Mavi kareler falan. Öyle düşünün. Sonra
fakat çevresinden çeşitli özelliklerle
ayrılan coğrafi birimdir. Bu mavi kare
kendi içinde çeşitli benzerlikler
gösteriyor ama çevresinden
benzerlikleriyle ayrılan coğrafi
birimlerdir bölgeler. Yani sizin asıl
bilmeniz gereken şurası. Bölge
türlerinin şu ayrımını yapabilmeniz
lazım sizin. Gençler biz bölgeyi ikiye
ayırıyoruz. Bakın şekilsel bölgeler,
işlevsel bölgeler. Bunu da ezberlemene
gerek yok. Bak işlevsel bölge dediğinde
birisi sana bir işi kolaylaştırmak için
yapılmış bölgeler diyeceksin buna. Bak
işlevsel ha bir işi kolaylaştırmak için
yapılmış bölgeler bunlar. Mesela
belediye yönetim bölgeleri. Bir iş
kolaylaştırmak için değil mi? Bir
merkezi var ve bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için yapılan bölgeler. İş olacak yani.
Bak bir daha. bölge türleri. He hocam
bir iş lazım bize. İşlevsel bölge diye
ayırdık. Bir de şekil lazım bize. İş
şekil. Hatta şöyle yapabiliriz. Şeklinin
başına i koyarız. Bak bu kodlamayı da
burada çıkarttım ilk defa. İş şekil. İş
şekil. Böylece iki tane ayrımı da bulmuş
olur. Birisi bize o zaman bölge dediği
zaman şekil diyeceksin. Ha iş şekil ha
hocam işlevsel bölgeler şekilsel
bölgeler olarak ayıracağız. Tamam merak
etme. Şimdi tek tek bunları göstereceğim
sana. Şekilsel bölgelere bak. Şimdi
tanıdık gelmesi lazım sana şekilsel
bölgeler. Bak coğrafyayı biz kaça
ayırıyorduk? İkiye. Hep ayrımlarımız
bunun üzerinden gidiyordu. Fiziki
coğrafya yani doğal coğrafya. Bir de
beşeri coğrafya. Bakın, beşeri coğrafya.
İşte şekilsel bölgeleri aynı coğrafya
gibi ikiye ayıracaksın. Coğrafyanın
ayrımını yapacaksın burada. Ha
diyeceksin hocam şekilsel bölge. Ha o
zaman bunu doğal şekiller, beşeri
şekiller diye ayıracaksın. Bak doğal
işlevler, beşeri işlevler olmuyor.
Görüyor musunuz? Bak beşeri işlevler
olmuyor. Beşeri şekiller oluyor. Bak
doğal işlevler olmuyor. Doğal şekiller
oluyor. Ha, demek ki bu işlevsel
bölgenin altında değil. Tamam. Ne
yaptım? Şekilsel bölge dedim. Ha doğal
şekiller. Coğrafya gibi ayırdım. Beşeri
şekiller. Anlaştık mı? Bak şimdi kenara
geliyorum. Bir tane boşluk bulayım. Bu
boşlukta sana bunun mantığını bir kere
daha sen de yazarak öğren. Bir tane
kağıt al. Bu ayrımı yapabilmen gerekiyor
çünkü. Şimdi bana biri sordu. Bölgeleri
tablo olarak ayır dedi bana. Hemen bölge
yazdım. Sonra dedim ki he bu bölgelerde
şekil vardı. Şekil. Şekil şekil. He
hocam bak. Şekil. Ha bunun başına bir
tane i koyuyordum. İşlevsel bölge. O
zaman bir tanesi şekilsel bölge diğeri
de işlevsel bölge diyeceksin. Bak adım
adım anlatıyorum. Hiç acele etmiyorum.
Sen de acele etme. 2x'ten çıkart bu
videonun burasını. Hiç yoktan 1'e 1,5'ğa
düşür. Tamam. Çünkü bunu böyle algılaman
gerekiyor. Sonra baktım şekilsel bölge.
He hocam burada şekil doğal şekiller.
Coğrafyanın alt dallarını düşünüyordum.
Doğal şekilsel bölgeler. Bir de ne
vardı? beşeri insanla alakalı beşeri
şekilsel bölgeler diye ayıracağım. Bu
ayrımı böyle yapabilmen bizim için çok
değerli. Tamam. Şimdi geldim buraya. Bak
bunların örneklerini hocam sana
sorabilir. Nasıl soracak? Mesela şöyle
yakınlaşayım. Şekilsel bölgelerden
başlayalım. Bak yer şekillerine göre
bölgeler dikkat et. Yer şekli sana yazar
hocam. Yer şekline göre bölgeleri
bölgelerden hangisine koyacağız diye. E
hocam yer şekli doğal bir şey değil mi?
O zaman getirip bunu nereye koyacaksın?
doğal şekilsel bölgelerin altına
koyacaksın. Bak dikkat et. İklim. İki
tane iklim yazmışız buraya. Hidrografik
bölge. Bak toprak bölgesi. Bunların
hepsi doğal bir şey değil mi? Bitki
doğal bir şey değil mi? Doğal afetler
doğal bir şey. Bak görüyor musun? Doğal.
He. O zaman bunları doğal şekilsel
bölgeye koydum. Buraya bak şimdi.
Hammadde ve üretim. İnsanla alakalı bir
şey var burada. Sanayi, nüfus. E
bunların hepsi insan değil mi? Bak.
Yerleşme, kültür, siyasi. Bunların hepsi
ne? İnsanla alakalı. O zaman getirip
bunları beşeri şekilselin altına
koyacağım. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi bunlarla
alakalı örnekleri vereyim sana. Bak
doğal çekilsel bölgeler. Mesela bak
dünyadaki kasırga bölgeleri. E bu
insanla alakalı değil ki. Doğada yaşanan
bir şey. O zaman ben bunu ne yapacağım
hocam? Hemen burada ayrımını yapalım.
Bak bölge bana dedi ki soruda. Dünyadaki
kasırga bölgeleri bölgelerden hangisine
girer? He bölgeyi yazdım. Sonra dedim ki
bir işi kolaylaştırmak için bölgeler
var. İşlevsel bölge. Şöyle işlevsel
bölge. Bir de şekil vardı. Şekilsel
bölge. Hocam bu doğayile alakalı. O
zaman bunu ben doğal şekilsel bölgelerin
altına koyacağım. Anlaştık mı? Mantığı
bu. Bakın Türkiye'deki bitki örtüsü
bölgelerini koymuş. E neyle alakalı?
Bitki. E o zaman doğal bir şey. Doğal
şekilsel bölge. Bak toprak tiplerine
göre bölge iklimine göre. Mesela buraya
koymuş bak. Ekvatoral ikliminin dağılış
haritasını koymuş. Bunu o zaman. He
hocam bu şekilsel ama nasıl? doğal
şekilsel bölge içerisine koyacağım.
Buradaki mantığı anladınız mı? Tamam.
Bak, yer şekilleri bölgesi. He, yer
şekilleri. He. Bu bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için yapılmış bir şey değil bu. Bu
şekille alakalı. Peki beşeri şekil mi,
doğal şekil mi? Ha hocam bu doğal bir
şekil. O zaman doğal şekilsel bölgeye
girer diyeceğim. Tamam. Bu ayrımı bu
şekilde yapabilmeniz lazım. Beşeri
şekilsel bölgelere bakalım. Şimdi bak
burada ne vermiş haritada? Türkiye'nin
yoğun ve seyrek nüfuslu bölgeleri. Ha
nüfusla alakalı. O zaman ben bunun hemen
tablosunu yapayım. Bölge dedim hocam. Bu
işlevsel bölge olur mu? Hayır iş değil
bu. Bir şekil bu. Coğrafyanın alt dalı
gibi. Peki doğal olur mu bu? He bu nüfus
insanla alakalı doğal değil demek ki. O
zaman buna ne diyeceğim? Beşeri şekilsel
bölge diyeceğim. Buradaki ayrımı ve
tanımı ve öğrenmeyi böyle yapacaksın.
Bak nüfus öyle. Bak hammadde üretim
bölgesi üretim diyor insanla alakalı.
Kültür diyor insanla alakalı. Yerleşme
insanla alakalı. Bunların hepsi neyle
alakalı o zaman? Beşeri şekilsel bölge
ile alakalı. Tamam. Geliyorum şimdi şu
tablonun başına dönelim. Bir de burada
bakın işlevsel bölgeler var. İşlevsel
bölge dediğimiz ne biliyor musunuz? Bir
işi kolaylaştırmak için yapılmış
bölgeler bunlar. Bunların bir merkezi
var ve bu merkez doğrultusunda
yönetiliyorlar. Nedir hocam bunlar?
Gelin bakın. Bakın şimdi şurada işlevsel
bölge. Birincisi yönetim bölgesi. Şimdi
siz Türkiye'yi yönetim bölgelerine
ayırmazsanız yönetebilir misiniz? Tabii
ki yönetilir ama zor olur değil mi?
Kolaylaştırmak için ne yapmışlar? Mesela
bunu bilmenize gerek yok illa böyle.
Şuradaki kısmı bilmenize gerek yok. Şunu
bilmeniz yeterli. Demek ki yönetim
bölgesi olarak ayırdım ben. Bak bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için mi? Bak yönetim işi.
Bak yönetim şekli değil işte yönetim
doğal şekli. Yönetim beşeri şekli değil.
Yönetim işi. Ha, bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için yapılmış bölge demek ki. Bu nasıl
ayırıyorlar bunu? Merkezi yönetimler
gençler. Mesela kaymakamlık valilik
devlet tarafından atanır ilçelere,
illere ve kaymakamlık valilik devlet
tarafından yönetim yapar. Bak bunu
devlet yapar. Merkezden atanır bunlar. O
yüzden buna merkezi yönetim denir. Bir
işi kolaylaştırmak için mi yapılmış? Ha
işlevsel bölge. Bir tane daha. Bu da
yerel yönetim bölgeleri. Yerel
yönetimden kastımız da gençler mesela
büyükşehir, il, ilçe, belediyeler değil
mi? Belediyeler. Bu merkezden atanmaz.
Devlet tarafından atanmaz. Bunu kim
yapar? İnsanlar kendileri seçer,
belediyeleri. Yani aslında yönetimler
iki şekildedir Türkiye'de. Bir tane
mesela sizin ilçenizde, tamam mı? Bir
tane belediye vardır. Belediye başkanı
vardır. Bunu halk seçer. Bu yerel
yönetimdir. Bir tane de merkezi yönetim.
Devletin atadığı biri vardır. Kaymakam.
O da devlet adına yönetim yapar orada.
Anladık mı oradaki mantığı? Bak bunlar
ne? Yönetim yapıyor. Ha yönetim bir işi
kolaylaştırıyorlar aslında. Bakın
Büyükşehir İstanbul Büyükşehir
Belediyesi ha bir işi kolaylaştırmak
işlevsel bölge. İşlevsel bölgelerden
hangisine giriyor? Yönetim bölgesine
girmiş oluyor. Buradaki mantığı anladık
mı? Bir diğer bölge türü de gençler
yönetim bölgesi birdi. İkincisi kalkınma
işi. Bak görüyor musun? İş kelimesi
nasıl uyuyor? Ha, kalkınma işi. Kalkınma
işlevsel bir bölge. Ne demek bu gençler?
Ülkemizde çeşitli kalkınma bölgelerine
ayır ayrılmıştır bizim ülkemiz. Bakın
özellikle doğu kesiminde bu kalkınma
bölgeleri var. Kalkınma bak adı üstünde
kalkınma. Çünkü doğuda sanayi
yapamıyoruz. Doğuda imkanlar daha
kısıtlı. Ya devlet oradaki insanların
batıya göç etmesini istemiyor. Herkes
kendi bulunduğu bölgede tarımını,
hayvancılığını yapsın. O bölgede dursun.
Kalkınmamız Türkiye'nin her tarafına
yayılsın diye kalkınma projeleri yapar.
Devlet mesela bunlardan belki senin en
bildiğin, bu biraz AYT konusu en
bildiğin senin Güneydoğu Anadolu GAP'ı
bilirsin bak GAP'ı duymuşsundur. Mesela
burada da KOP var. Konya Ovası projesi
gibi. DAP var Doğu Anadolu projesi gibi.
DOKAP var mesela şöyle DOKAP Doğu
Karadeniz projesi gibi. Ama bunlardan
GAP'ı bilirsin. GAP Güneydoğu Anadolu
projesi. Bu proje bir bunların hepsi bir
kalkınma projesi. Kalkınma işi. Bir
merkezi var bunların. Bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için bu bölgeleri
ayırmışız gap diye. Burada bir iş
yapılıyor. Buranın kalkınması için
çeşitli işler yapılıyor gibi düşün bunu.
Demek ki işlevsel bölgeleri ne yaptık
şimdi? Yönetim işi diye ayırdık.
Kalkınma işlevsel bölgeleri diye
ayırdık. Gelelim diğerine. Hizmet
bölgeleri. Bakın hizmet işi. Hizmet
şekli olmaz yani. Hizmet şekil doğal
şekiller olmuyor. Bak hizmet işi var. Ha
hocam hizmet işinde de devlet hizmet
götürecek ya. hizmet bölgelerine
ayırması gerekiyor. Hizmetten kastımız
şu bakın. Devlet Su İşleri Hizmet
Bölgesi. Görüyor musunuz? Orman Genel
Müdürlüğü Hizmet Bölgesi. Karayolları
Genel Müdürlüğü. Bak bunların hepsi
hizmet için varlar. Demek ki bir diğeri
de hizmet bölgesi. Bir diğeri sonuncusu
şöyle. Bu da istatistik bölgeleri.
İstatistik işi var. Bu işi
sağlayabilmemiz için TÜİK gençler
istatistik bölgelerine bölmüş ülkeyi.
Bakın bunlar da istatistik bölgeleri.
İstatistik işi. Şimdi en başa geliyorum.
En başa şöyle bir tekrar bir görelim
şurayı. Şunları sileyim. Şöyle işlevsel
bölgelere bak. Bölgeleri ayırdık abi.
Şekilsel dedik. Aa başına i koyduk.
İşlevsel bölge diye de bir tane daha
ayrım yap. Sonra iş, bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için bak hizmet işi,
işlevsel bölge, kalkınma işi, işlevsel
bölge, yönetim işi ve istatistik işi.
Bunlar da bizim işlevsel bölgelerimiz.
Bunları aynı böyle bilmen gerekiyor.
Bunlara örnek verebilmelisin. Mesela
sana örnekten kastımız şu. Sana derse,
"Kalkınma projesi bölgesi hangi bölge
türüne girer?" Sen bunun bir iş bölgesi
olduğunu bilmen gerekiyor. Ya da sana
gelip Türkiye'nin toprak bölgesi
hangisine girer dediğinde a bu doğal
şekil içerisine girer. Bu ayrımı
yapabilmen gerekiyor. Tamam. Bölge
türlerinin mantığı budur gençler. Mesela
buradan evet örnekleri verdik aslında.
Bir daha vermeye gerek yok. Şimdi bir de
bölge sınırlarının bölge sınırları ile
alakalı bazı özellikler var. Bu
özellikleri bilmen lazım. Şu özellik
bizim için çok önemli. Bölge
sınırlarının ayrılması. Bak bunu
dikkatli dinle gençler. Bölgelerin
sınırlarını böyle keskin hatlarla
ayırmak zor oluyor. Özellikle de doğal
bölgelerin sınırlarını ayırmak zor
oluyor. Mesela ne demek istediğimi
şuradaki örnekler üzerinden anlatayım.
Şurada doğal bölgelerden bir örnek
çıkartayım. Mesela şu Türkiye'deki yer
şekillerine göre bölgeler. Bunu değil de
daha böyle anlayabileceğin ha şu mesela
Türkiye'deki bitki örtüsüne bölgeler
göre bölgeler. Şimdi sen bitkinin
sınırlarını kolay ayırabilir misin?
Böyle mi gerçekten? Bu haritada olduğu
gibi mi? Ben bu haritanın şurasındayken
şurasına bir adım attığımda şuradayım
ya. Şimdi ben buradan şuraya bir adım
attım. Ha bitki direkt değişti. Ya da
iklim. Burada Akdeniz iklimi var. Bir
adım attım diğer tarafa. Akdeniz iklimi
direkt değişti. Böyle bir şey olabilir
mi? Yok. Demek kademeli bir geçiş
gösterir. Bölge sınırlarını keskin
hatlarla doğal bölgelerde ayırmak zor
oluyor. Doğal bölgelerden kastımız şuydu
bakın. Yani şuradaki doğal bölgelerde
bölgelerin sınırlarını ayırmak zor
oluyor. Bunu ezberleme. Bunun mantığını
şöyle düşün. Şimdi sen iklim bölgesini
sınırını böyle çizgi halinde çizebilir
misin? Çizdim. Burası Akdeniz, burası
Karadeniz. Yok değil mi? Akdeniz ve
Karadeniz bazı yerlerde birbirine
geçmiştir. Tam olarak sınırlarını böyle
ayıramazsın. İşte en önemli
özelliklerimizden bir tanesi bu. Bölge
sınırlarının ayrılması. Yani doğal bölge
sınırları ayrılırken kademeli geçiş
gösterir. Keskin hatlarla ayırmak
zordur. Tamam. Ama bakın burada beşeri
bölge sınırlarını, işlevsel bölge
sınırlarını daha kolay ayırabiliyoruz.
Mesela beşeri bölgeden kastımız şurası.
Bak tak ülkenin neiyle ili alakalı değil
mi? E ilini içine aldığımızda tak sınırı
belli oldu. Gördünüz mü? Bak tak.
Ankara'da nüfus yoğundur dedik. Baktık
sınırını belli ettik. Ankara'nın il
sınırıyla örtüştüğü için keskin bir
şekilde ayırabildik. Ya da kalkınma
bölgesi. Bak burada kalkınma bölgesi.
Ben gitsem burada Diyarbakır'ın tam şu
uç kesimine ve bu uç kesimin de bu
tarafa gelsem Diyarbakır'a gelsem
kalkınma bölgesinin içinde olurum. Bir
diğer tarafa gitsem mesela orada Bingöl
tarafına gitsem bir adım kalkınma
bölgesinden çıkarım değil mi? Bak ne
oldu? Daha böyle işlevsel bölgeleri
keskin hatlarla ayırabildik ama doğal
bölgeleri keskin hatlarla ayırmak daha
zor oldu. Buradaki mantık bu olacak.
Bununla alakalı sana böyle bir yorum
sorusu sorulabilir. Bir diğeri
bölgelerin sınırlarının değişmesi.
Bölgelerin sınırı değişir. Değişebilir
gençler. Yine aynı mantık var. Bakın sen
şimdi doğal bölgeleri değiştirmek. Doğal
bölgeleri değiştirmeye kalktığında sen
zorlanırsın. Daha uzun zamanlarda
değişir. Mesela yine iklime örnek ver.
Hep bu iklim aklında olsun. Sen şimdi
iklim bir doğal bölge. İklimin değişmesi
çok uzun sürer değil mi? yıllar alır.
Bak iklim uzun sürede değişir. Yani
doğal şekilsel bölgelerin sınırlarının
değişmesi yavaş gerçekleşir. Ama mesela
siyasi bölgeler şunun gibi ülke
sınırlarını kapsayan, illerin
sınırlarını kapsayan bölgeleri değişmesi
kolaydır. Neden? Mesela İngiltere Avrupa
Birliği'nin bir üyesiydi. İngiltere
Avrupa Birliği'nden çıktı. Tık hemen
çıkınca bak sınır değişti. Gördünüz mü?
İklimi böyle değiştirebilir misiniz?
Değiştiremezsiniz. Buradaki mantığı buna
göre kurgulayacaksın. Anlaştık mı? Bölge
sınırları da demek ki değişirmiş. Bölge
sınırlarının çakışması gençler. Çakışma
derken şu. Mesela burası bitki bölgesi.
Tamam mı? İşte ne diyelim? Eee, Bozkır
bitki bölgesi. Bozkır bitki bölgesiyle
toprak bozkır kahverengi bozkır toprak
bölgesi çakışabilir mesela. Aynı aynı
yerler hemen hemen çünkü değil mi? ya da
nüfusun seyrek olduğu bölgeyle bu bozkır
alanları çakışabilir. Bozkır yani
bölgelerin sınırlarının çakışmasından
kastı da bu. Evet, bölge konusu gençler
çok basit bir konudur. Çok kolay bir
konudur. Mantığı da size anlattığım
şekilde böyledir. Tamam mıyız? Burada
çok kısa bir derstir bu ama çok değerli
bir derstir. Özellikle şuradaki ayrımı
yapabilmeniz lazım. Bu ayrımı bir kere
daha benimle beraber şu boş çizelgede
yapalım. Bölge yazdım. Şöyle biraz
kalınlaştırayım. Bölgelere ayır dedi ve
bunlara örnekler ver dedi. Tamam mı?
Bölge yazdım, getirdim. İkiye
ayıracağım. Hocam şekil vardı. He
şekilsel bölge. Başına bir i koyuyordum
iş oluyordu. Bir de ne vardı? İşlevsel
bölge vardı. İşlevsel bölge. Sonra
şekilsel bölgeyi hocam şekilsel bölgeyi
de ben ikiye ayırıyordum. Doğal
şekiller, beşeri şekiller. Beşeri
şekiller. Bu tarafta işlevsel bölgeyi
ona ayırmıyordum. O tekti. Peki işlevsel
bölgelere örnek verecek olursak ne
diyorduk? Kalkınma işi vardı değil mi?
Kalkınma bölgeleri. Başka hizmet
yapıyordu devlet. Devlet Su İşleri gibi
hizmet bölgeleri vardı. Başka?
İstatistik. İstatistik bölgeleri vardı.
Başka? Kalkınma, hizmet. İstatistik. Ha
bir de yönetim vardı değil mi?
Yönetiyorduk. Yönetim bölgeleri vardı.
Merkezi yönetim, yerel yönetim diye.
Doğal şekilsel bölgeleri nasıl
yapıyorduk hocam? Bunlara da işte bitki
örtüsüne göre bölgeler, toprağına göre
bölgeler, yer şekillerine göre bölgeler,
değil mi? iklimine göre yani doğayile
alakalı olanları yazıyorduk. Beşeriyede
hammadde bölgesi mesela hammadde
bölgesi, nüfus bölgesi, insanla alakalı
yerleşim bölgesi bu şekilde
yerleştirirseniz sorun yaşamazsınız.
İşinizi görür. Evet, bölgeler konusunu
da bitirdik. Evet gençler bölgeler
konusu çok kısa bir konudur. Önemli bir
konudur ama değerli bir konudur. Hızlı
bir şekilde bitirdik. Bu konuyu o
tabloları bilmen üniversite sınavında
çok işimize yarayacak diyoruz. O zaman
ne diyoruz? Yunus hocayla bir defa
öğren. Bir daha asla unutma.